ich bin Wehrpflichtiger und habe mich
vor der Armee gedrückt deswegen bin ich
hier
Alexander und serafima haben alles
zurückgelassen von heute auf morgen sind
sie aus ihrer Heimat Russland geflohen
vor dem Schicksal das putins-regime für
sie vorgesehen hat als wir sie treffen
sind sie den ersten Tag in Kasachstan
ich soll im Oktober eingezogen werden da
habe ich entschieden dass es besser ist
wenn ich nichts riskiere und Ausreise
[Musik]
für ihn die richtige Entscheidung wie
sich zeigen sollte denn nur eine Woche
später verkündet Putin die
Teilmobilmachung sie brauchen dringend
einen Bankkonto in Kasachstan ihre
russischen Kreditkarten sind hier
nutzlos wegen der westlichen Sanktionen
können Sie nirgends bezahlen
die Karte wurde sofort gedruckt man muss
nicht warten der Bankautomat gibt sie
gleich aus
so eine goldene Karte ist das
Kreditkarten sind in Kasachstan leicht
zu bekommen Russlands Kritikern dienen
sie als Ausweg in ein selbstbestimmtes
Leben doch es kommen auch zehntausende
die das System ausnutzen sie brauchen
die Kreditkarten um Geschäfte in Putins
Russland zu machen um westliche
Sanktionen zu umgehen Kasachstan lässt
das zu die wirtschaftliche Abhängigkeit
vom mächtigen Nachbarn ist zu groß
[Musik]
noch die Kasachen werden selbstbewusster
in der Millionenmetropole almati mischt
sich sowjetisches Erbe mit
Aufbruchsstimmung immer deutlicher
richtet sich der Blick auch nach Westen
und schon seit Jahren ist es ein
Zufluchtsort für junge Russen und
Russinnen
so wie Anastasia in den Hinterhöfen der
Stadt organisiert die Russin Hilfe für
die Ukraine zusammen mit Valentin einem
Ukrainer
als wir mit diesem Projekt anfingen habe
ich nur wenigen gesagt dass ich aus
Russland bin ich habe mich
geschämtsam
die Ukraine da ist mir egal ob sie
Russen oder nicht Russen sind wenn
jemand Anstand hat mache ich keinen
Unterschied
Anastasia kam 2016 nach Kasachstan das
Russland die Krim annektierte war der
Auslöser ihrer Heimat zu verlassen dann
kam der 24 Februar ihre schamrusseln zu
sein wurde so groß dass sie der Ukraine
helfen wollte dafür bezahlt sie einen
hohen Preis
solange sich nichts an dem Regime in
meinem Land ändert werde ich nicht
dorthin zurückgehen denn ich habe Angst
ich habe einfach aus menschlicher Sicht
Angst ich 37 ich möchte nicht ins
Gefängnis kommen
und so packen Sie hier unermüdlich
Pakete für die Ukraine Lebensmittel
Babynahrung das Nötigste
[Musik]
diese Frau kommt um einen Blumenkranz zu
kaufen als Zeichen der Solidarität
diese Grenze hier kaufen und so der
Organisation ein wenig helfen es sind
wie Sie sehen sehr schöne kleine Grenze
gefällt dir
die Hilfsbereitschaft ist großer zählen
sie uns Russen Ukrainer und Kasachen
helfen hier gemeinsam
chasslow und Islam gehen noch zur Schule
sie sind mit ihrem Lehrer hergekommen
weil wir von der Ukraine gehört hatten
was ich dort ereignet nun was insgesamt
in der Welt geschieht natürlich haben
wir entschieden mit allem zu helfen
womit wir können
die Hilfe wird auch denen zu teil die
nach Kasachstan geflohen sind wir sind
auf dem Weg zu einer Familie deren
Flucht ausgerechnet über die russische
Grenze führte
Ivan und seine Schwester Xenia kommen
beide aus der Ostukraine das Xenia jetzt
hier ist hat sie ihrem Bruder zu
verdanken er war schon einige Jahre in
Kasachstan als Russland und seiner
Heimat einmarschierte die Stadt in der
Xenia und ihre Mutter wohnten wurde
schon nach kurzer Zeit eingenommen
einen Monat nach Beginn des Krieges
hatten russische Soldaten die
Nachrichtenverbindungen in die Stadt
gekappt die Stromversorgung ich hatte
jeglichen Kontakt zu meiner Mutter und
meiner Schwester verloren
es gab überhaupt keine Verbindung mehr
nichts
fieberhaft überlegte Ivan damals wie er
seine Familie rausholen kann er ließ
seiner Mutter über russische Verwandte
eine Videobotschaft zukommen um sie zur
Flucht zu überreden keine einfache
Entscheidung denn die Flucht führte über
Russland vorbei an Soldaten Grenzbeamten
bevor wir die Ukraine verließen habe ich
mich noch von meiner besten Freundin
verabschiedet mit der ich schon sechs
Jahre befreundet bin wir hatten kaum
Zeit uns zu verabschieden dann reisten
wir aus da waren viele Soldaten
was schlimm ja Panzer waren auf den
Straßen Schützenpanzer Kriegsfahrzeuge
Ivan und Xenias Heimatstadt kobiansk im
Osten der Ukraine ist inzwischen befreit
trotzdem wird ihr Leben nie wieder so
sein wie es mal war
ich möchte gerne meine Heimatstadt in
mein Land zurückkehren
und wann
ich weiß es nicht wenn der Krieg zu Ende
ist
bis ihre Heimat wieder sicher ist werden
sie wohl in almati wohnen bleiben
ausgerechnet dass sie Russisch sprechen
ist ein Vorteil für Sie
denn in der ehemaligen Sowjetrepublik
spricht fast jeder russisch kasachstan
ist eng verflochten mit dem mächtigen
Nachbarn sprachlich kulturell
wirtschaftlich russische Unternehmen die
von westlichen Sanktionen betroffen sind
verlagern ihre Geschäfte deshalb auch
nach Kasachstan
[Musik]
Vadim ist Jurist Lebenskünstler
Kleinunternehmer er erzählt uns es sei
ein leichtes sanktionierte Produkte über
Kasachstan nach Russland zu importieren
die Sanktionen gegen Russland
funktionieren kann man an einem so
banalen Beispiel sehen wie am Autokauf
die halbe Welt weigert sich Autos nach
Russland zu liefern aber russische
Bürger können Sie ganz einfach bei uns
hier kaufen
eine Praxis die Kasachstan irgendwann
verboten hat weil plötzlich viele Russen
kamen um hier Autos zu kaufen aber
wie gesagt den Autokauf an ausländische
Bürger zu verbieten das funktioniert gar
nicht zum Beispiel ich
zu mir kamen Bekannte aus Russland und
baten mich Ihnen zu helfen ein Auto zu
kaufen
wir gingen ins Geschäft kauften das Auto
und registrierten es einfach auf einen
kasachischen Bekannten von mir
Kasachstans Regierung will Russland
nicht verärgern aber auch nicht zum
Komplizen von Putins Regime werden
spätestens seit der russischen Invasion
in die Ukraine sucht das Land neue
Partner auch unter Russlands Feinden
kasachstan hat was Europa so dringend
braucht Gas und Öl doch es ist ein
gefährlicher Spagat
im Westen des Landes holen hunderte
Pumpen in Minuten Taktöl aus der Erde
die Menschen in der Region sind auf den
Export des wertvollen Rohstoffs
angewiesen
ich habe den Beruf geerbt mein Vater hat
schon hier gearbeitet man gehört damit
zur Elite
die Bedingungen sind gut alle wollen
erdölarbeiter werden
[Musik]
der Leiter der Produktion erklärt sie
fördern hier Erdöl und Gas aber nur das
Öl werde ins Ausland geliefert in der
aktuellen Lage ist das schwierig denn
80% fließen durch russische Pipelines
beraten
Erdöl ist eine Lokomotive für die
Wirtschaft des ganzen Landes
aber in den vergangenen Jahren ist wegen
der Pandemie und anderen äußeren Gründen
die Förderung gesunken
[Musik]
er nennt es nicht beim Namen aber
Russland blockierte zuletzt mehrmals den
Export aus fadenscheinigen Gründen an
Zufall glaubt kaum jemand in einer Zeit
in der sich Kasachstan an Europa
annähert für die Einwohner der
angrenzenden Siedlungen wird es schnell
existenzbedrohend
[Musik]
außer Erdöl haben wir fast gar nichts
all die Arbeit alles hängt vom Öl ab
kannst du jetzt
wozu brauchen wir Russland wir sind
Kasachstan wir sind Kasachen das ist
unsere Heimat unser Öl vorher Alter
Kasachstan will mehr Öl über das
Kaspische Meer nach Europa Verschiffen
doch die Kapazitäten sind begrenzt sich
vom mächtigen Nachbarn zu lösen ist
daher schwierig noch hat Russland die
Macht über den Rohstoff
wir treffen noch einmal Alexander der
nun seit einer Woche in almati lebt er
hat eine Wohnung gefunden fühlt sich
wohl hier in Russland hat er in der
IT-Branche gearbeitet einen Job den er
auch aus dem neuen Zuhause machen kann
er weiß wie gefährlich es ist sich
kritisch über Russland zu äußern aber
Alexander will sich nicht einschüchtern
lassen eine Rückkehr ist für den Anfang
20-jährigen sowieso völlig ungewiss
nun es hängt davon ab wie der Krieg
endet welche Art von Regime es nach
Putin sein wird und bis ich 27 bin werde
ich sowieso Abstand halten zum
russischen militäreinberufungsamt und
selbst danach gehe ich wahrscheinlich
aus Kasachstan woanders hin aber nicht
nach Russland bisher sind das nur
waagepläne nichts Konkretes
das einzige die Russen im Exil
langfristige Pläne macht hier niemand
sie hoffen irgendwann zurückzukehren
aber erst wenn sie sich in ihrer Heimat
wieder sicher fühlen